hey this is presh talwalker two dice A
and B are numbered one to six but each
dice is unfair the numbers one to six do
not all show with equal chance
if you roll the two dice their sum will
be a whole number from 2 to 12.
prove it is impossible that all of the
sums can occur with equal chance
I saw this interesting problem on math
stack Exchange
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
we can solve this problem with a proof
by contradiction
suppose dice a has probabilities of P1
to P6 for its faces one to six similarly
suppose that dice B has probabilities of
q1 to q6
each probability is a non-negative
number that does not exceed one
now let's suppose that all of the sums
do occur with equal chance that will
mean a probability of 1 over 11 to each
of the 11 possible sums from 2 to 12.
now what's the probability that we will
have a sum that's equal to 2.
there's only one way that we can get a
sum of two which is one plus one so the
probability will be P1 multiplied by q1
and we know that each of the sums has a
probability of 1 over 11. so P1 q1 is
equal to 1 over 11. similarly there's
only one way to get a sum of 12 which is
six plus six so we have P6 q6 is equal
to 1 over 11.
now what about a sum of seven
there are many different ways that we
can get a sum of seven and the sum of
all of these probabilities is equal to 1
over 11.
now each of these probabilities is a
non-negative number so if we remove
these terms we are possibly removing
some non-negative numbers here
so this will result in an inequality we
have P1 q6 plus P6 q1 is less than or
equal to 1 over 11.
now since P1 q1 is equal to 1 over 11
neither of the probabilities is equal to
zero and similarly
P6 times q6 is equal to 1 over 11. so P6
and q6 are also not equal to zero
so let's focus on a couple of these
things we've derived
since we know that P1 and q6 are not
equal to zero this must be a positive
term P1 multiplied by q6
similarly P6 multiplied by q1 must also
be a positive term because neither is
equal to zero
this means that P1 q6 is less than 1
over 11 and P6 q1 is also less than 1
over 11.
so now let's further continue our
analysis considering the first equation
and this first inequality we can
conclude that P1 q6 is less than P1 q1
considering this pair we must have that
P6 q1 is less than P1 q1
from here we will have that P6 q1 is
less than P6 q6 and finally we have that
P1 q6 is less than P6 q6
since we know that none of these
probabilities is equal to zero and each
of the probabilities is a non-negative
number not exceeding one we can cancel
out these probabilities on these
inequalities
in the first inequality we can cancel
out P1 from both sides giving that q6 is
less than q1
in the next inequality we can cancel out
q1 from both sides giving P6 is less
than P1
and the third inequality we can cancel
out P6 which gives that q1 is less than
q6 and in the final inequality we can
cancel out q6 leaving the inequality
that P1 is less than P6
but wait a minute we've derived that q6
is less than q1 and we've also derived
that q1 is less than q6 this is a
contradiction similarly we've derived
that P6 is less than P1 and the reverse
therefore we've derived a contradiction
and it is not possible that all of these
sums occur with equal chance
and that concludes the proof
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]